I'm in London to
meet Joshua Coombes.
He's a hairdresser.
And he believes small acts of
love can make a big impact.
Joshua hopes he can
help the homeless,
not by offering
them money or food
but by giving them a haircut.
The reason I started cutting
hair on the street, initially,
was actually the
magnitude of the problem,
like seeing how big this
problem is in each city.
It's really hard to know
what to do about that.
And I think it was from that
feeling I had to impact today.
I had to do something positive
to make someone smile.
And realize that
even if you can't
solve the problem, actually it's
OK to just do your own thing.
And for me, that's hairdressing.
I love what I do, so it's a
great way to be able to give
someone confidence.
When was the last time
you had a haircut?
In November last year.
So January, February.
Five months to March, April.
How did you come to
be homeless, Stuart?
I broke my hip and
they stopped my benefits.
At the time, I was
like, that's stupid.
And involved with
drugs and things.
I didn't really care.
And next thing, [inaudible].
That was 24th of January, 2016.
And I've been homeless since.
You see lots of things
with homelessness.
And there's lots of stereotypes.
And really, what I do is
try and humanize this issue.
Because as I said,
this problem is so big,
I think when you bring
it down to one person
and tell the story, that's
a great way to start
and a great way for
people to understand.
For me, like one of
the most amazing moments
is giving someone the mirror
at the end of their haircut
because it's great to
see someone's reaction
because they might
recognize someone they
haven't seen for a few years.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Ta-da.
I'm 20 years younger.
[inaudible]
Nobody's going
to recognize me.
Mate, you're a
new man right now.
Yeah, thank you.
How do you feel?
Like a new man.
Do you recognize yourself there?